valerie jarrett former senior adviser to
president obama
joins us valerie good morning thanks for
being with us no one quite knew what to
expect with this unconventional
convention this year do you think it's
delivering on what the democrats need to
do
oh absolutely the first two nights have
been terrific
i think that the convention has
reflected the rich diversity of our
country
the combination of leaders for example
last night such as colin powell or
former president bill clinton but also
amazing people i was so struck last
night by jacqueline britney the elevator
operator
who got to know vice president biden and
who said
he saw her he paid attention to her and
so both the experience and the character
vice president behind this come
has already come through but also just
the broad range of people
who support him and want to move in a
new direction yeah you mentioned
jacqueline brittany who placed
who placed joe biden's name into
nomination last night
but and there's a there was a very large
supporting cast of just ordinary folks
who normally at a convention you do see
ordinary people but they give speeches
which is a little different than this
do you think having so many ordinary
people do they resonate more with the
polit than the political leaders
i think so because i think the american
people want to hear from people
who have shared their experiences and so
folks who
the more the most powerful i think
ordinary person the first night was the
woman
who lost her father to covet 19 and she
said her
his pre-existing condition was president
trump
so i think these stories resonate they
touch people very deeply
but then we also have people like
michelle obama who
obviously the most popular uh person in
the country and to have her
really validate both his uh intellect
his
competency his character and his empathy
all of it i think together has made a
very strong case for vice president
biden
and senator harris what did you think of
michelle obama's speech
[Music]
it was quite powerful i think she spoke
from the heart forthrightly as she
always does
and think about the arc of her time
speaking at conventions going from
being a victim of sexist and racist
tropes herself back in 2008
to earning the trust and confidence and
respect of people all around our country
red states blue states alike
and it gave her a chance to really
validate somebody who she knows so well
and speak to his uh qualities for
president so
i thought it was a home run and i'm
looking forward to tonight
there was some grumbling among
progressives that uh representative
alexandria ocasio-cortez
uh was just given a minute and 36
seconds to place
uh bernie sanders name into nomination
it it was
uh it was a it was a form a formal role
that she was actually asked to do
but but there was a lot of grumbling
about it what did you make of that
well so senator sanders asked you to do
to put his name and nomination and all
of the folks who did the nominations
did it the exact same length of time and
so that's the role that senator sanders
wanted her to have
and it was important to her and i think
to speak in his support
do you think i mean as i said you're the
party's trying to draw up from a broad
uh base of support including
progressives do you think it would have
benefited for giving
from giving her more time or a more
prominent role
i think that there are many progressives
who spoke on behalf of
vice president biden and i think senator
sanders speech
who represents that progressive movement
and his full-bodied endorsement
and his saying that look i'm going to
work with progressives i'm also going to
work with conservatives
send a very important message about the
direction we need to go
valerie jarrett i want to go back to
michelle obama for just a second you
know she's known for when we go
when they thought yes
i know i can't stop thinking about it to
be honest with you you know we
we her phrase when they go low we go
high is very well known i'd like to add
also we go in we go all the way there
were you surprised as someone who knows
her very well that she was that
candid that she wanted to make it clear
what she feels was at stake
not at all and gail if you know her well
as well too and
what she prides herself on is being very
honest with the american people
she loves our country she said clearly
she hates politics
yeah but she also wanted to explain why
uh vice president biden is the person
for this moment
and how president trump is not and she
feels this
deeply and she thought that for the
people who trust her
it was important for them to hear
directly from her what she thinks at
stake
what she thinks is at stake and how
important it is for everybody to vote
you know she was so disappointed at the
turnout and the 2016 election
so she's been working very hard to get
people registered to vote
and that was also the clearing call at
the end just not to inspire people gail
but to motivate them to actually get out
and vote yeah i felt it was
three years eight years and she was
finally saying listen please pay
attention to this this is important i
think
her message was heard loud and clear you
know barack obama very well too what do
you expect from him tonight
and i'm wondering if he's feeling
pressured because michelle obama seemed
to have knocked it out of the park
what do you think a little friendly
family competition you think
yeah i think yeah so i think president
obama is looking forward
to describing the person he knows so
well having worked with him
up close for eight years seeing how he
helped
president obama restore the economy pass
the affordable care act
uh have the gravitas on the world stage
that are that the world is hungry for
right now that we have lost
but also the man the person he knows so
well that he'd have lunch with who he
comforted
comforted after bo's death painful death
uh and i think he can speak to that
character issue
temperament uh and make a case for how
profoundly troubled he is in the
direction our country is going right now
so i think
he'll be very clear on that point too
all right well we'll all be watching
good to see you valerie jarrett senator
speaking tonight as well valerie jarrett
thanks so much